welcome back to understanding Quantum information and computation my name is John watus and I'm the technical
director for education at IBM Quantum this is the eth lesson of the series and it's the last lesson in the
second unit of the series which is on Quantum algorithms we've talked about the query model of computation including Quantum
algorithms that offer provable advantages over classical algorithms within that model we've discussed foundational Concepts connected with
Quantum algorithms and how we can measure computational cost and in the previous lesson we discussed phase estimation and Shores
algorithm in this lesson we'll discuss Grover's algorithm which provides a quadratic advantage of quantum over
classical algorithms for so-called unstructured search problems which I'll describe once we get into the
lesson these are all foundational topics concerning Quantum algorithms there are other Quantum
algorithms as well as general paradigms that Unite different Quantum algorithms and Quantum algorithmic techniques and
if you're interested I encourage you to check out the quantum algorithm Zoo which categorizes known Quantum algorithms and includes many references
to original research papers that have contributed to their development for this series however
we're just going to stick with the fundamentals and starting with the next lesson we'll move on to a new topic but
first let's talk about Grover's algorithm here is the lesson overview we'll begin with a short discussion of
the computational problem that we'll be addressing which is unstructured search intuitively speaking you can
think about the unstructured search problem as searching through a collection of items that isn't sorted and hasn't been ordered in a useful
way then we'll discuss Grover's algorithm which is a Quantum algorithm that offers a quadratic advantage over
classical algorithms and we'll get into precisely what that means shortly a very High Lev description of
how this algorithm works is that first there's an initialization step and then an operation that I'll refer to as the
grover operation is iterated some number of times and then finally a measurement takes place that reveals a candidate
solution to the search problem I'll explain what the grover operation is and how it can be
implemented on a quantum computer and then we'll go through an analysis of this operation to better understand what it does and why it's useful for
searching the third part of the lesson is concerned with the number of iterations
in Grover's algorithm or in other words the number of times the grover operation should be applied presuming that we wish
to maximize the likelihood that the algorithm succeeds in finding whatever it is that we're searching for while simultaneously minimizing its
cost we'll start with the unique search problem which is a special case in which there's exactly one solution to our
search problem and then we'll consider consider what happens when there are multiple Solutions and finally I'll conclude the
lesson with a few brief remarks about Grover's algorithm and its generalizations let's begin with the
computational problem that we'll be addressing throughout the lesson first as we often do we're going
to let Sigma denote the binary alphabet and we'll use this notation for the entirety of the lesson so I won't keep
reminding you suppose that we have a function f that Maps binary strings of some length n to
the binary alphabet our assumption is that we can easily evaluate this function for
example maybe we have a Boolean circuit for this function whose size is polinomial In N now this doesn't mean that this is
necessarily a simple function in any sense or that we have a particularly good understanding of this function for instance maybe we have a
rather complicated and messy Boolean ccle circuit for computing F that allows us to evaluate it on different input strings but doesn't necessarily have a
nice form that's designed to make our lives easier our goal is to find a solution by
which we mean a binary string of length n that causes F to evaluate to one in general this is a very difficult
computational problem or at least we suspect that is very difficult in particular if the input is in fact the
description of a Boolean circuit for Computing the function f then this is a so-called NP complete problem one way
that we can formalize this problem is as a query problem and indeed for the purposes of this lesson it's reasonable
to think about this problem purely in the context of the query model but when we think about where or when this
problem might arise in practice it's arguably more natural to think about f as being computed by a Boolean
circuit as we saw in lesson six though we can connect these two points of view through the construction that we went through for taking a Boolean circuit and
converting it into a Quantum circuit for implementing a query operation or a query gate in any case conceptually speaking
the input to the problem is this function f and we're looking for a solution if there is one and if there
isn't a solution meaning that F turns out to be the constant zero function then the correct output is to report
that there are no Solutions this is is an unstructured search problem in the sense that there's
nothing special about F that makes it easy to find a solution it's not like we're searching
through data that's already been ordered or that's been loaded into a data structure of some sort that facilitates searching and there's no promise on the
function f that might help us one way to think about it is that it's like searching for a particular
phone number in a phone book as opposed to searching for a name which is much easier presuming that the names have
been alphabetized in Practical terms it's not really about searching through data
which we tend to organize and store in a manner that makes searching easy it's more representative of searching for a
solution to a complicated equation for instance or perhaps searching for the combination that opens a
lock as an aside it is sensible to think about this problem in the context of the query model regardless of how we might
feel about the Practical relevance of that model of course there aren't oracles or blackboxes in real life but until we
learn otherwise complicated and mysterious Boolean circuits are kind of like black
boxes now let's think about algorithms for solving this unstructured search problem and we're going to be doing this
in the query model just for the sake of Simplicity if we have a Boolean circuit for our function rather than a black box
then we can still run query algorithms on it but of course we can't rule out the possibility that some new algorithm
is discovered for this problem that isn't based on making queries but we won't concern ourselves with that
possibility first just a little bit of notation the total number of input strings to the function f is 2 to the